new coronavirus variants have been
detected in over 40 countries
including the uk south africa nigeria
and brazil
where they first emerged now health
officials say a new threat is identified
in south africa
british officials imposed a new lockdown
across england
recent reports of a new highly
contagious coronavirus variant in the
united states
in the u.s multiple states have reported
new variants
or versions of the virus with mutations
that could change how it spreads
new research suggests that some of these
variants are highly transmissible
and at least one may reduce how well
vaccines work
with countries around the world already
facing escalating infections and
overwhelmed hospitals
these mutations could make ending the
pandemic more difficult
we'll explain like other viruses the
coronavirus spreads by infecting cells
and then reproducing within them
creating copies of itself that spread
throughout the body
as new versions are made the virus's
genetic code which holds the
instructions for building new virus
particles
is copied over and over again but the
code
isn't always reproduced correctly small
genetic mistakes
or mutations can create new viral
variants
if the new version of the virus has
mutations that allow it to spread faster
than the current most common variant
it could lead to a surge in new cases
this
is already happening in places like the
uk and south africa where some of the
newest ones were first found
current data suggests the uk variant
could be 50
to 70 percent more transmissible but the
research
is still early to determine how
transmissible
and dangerous a virus mutation might be
scientists run a series of experiments
in the lab the first step is genetic
sequencing
the genetic sequencing gets to the you
know the blueprint of what the viruses
are
we can use samples and data from
actual humans to figure out what the
genetics of the viruses are
to do this scientists take a sample of
the mutated virus and sequence its genes
then computational programs help
scientists identify mutations
once we know what they are and now we
can see that oh well this is an
important population
we can start manipulating the virus we
can either start working with clinical
isolates of that virus or we can
actually make
the strains so putting those individual
mutations into the backbone of viruses
that we already have
after sequencing the virus scientists
test the variant in a lab
what we do is we compare how well the
virus replicates
in different types of cells and so there
are two ways we will just do
infections and kind of measure the level
of the virus
over time in these cell types and the
other thing that we'll do is a
competition assay where we'll take
50 percent of the wild type the original
strain and 50
of the mutant strain and then compare
how well they grow
if there's an advantage we'll see that
that after 24 hours or after 48 hours
one of the two might out compete during
lab experiments
researchers can also test whether human
antibodies created by infection or
vaccines
are effective at fighting the new form
of the virus
after culture testing scientists
typically move on to animal models
and then sometimes to humans right now
the research is still
early but scientists are beginning to
get a clearer picture of what these
variants
look like from sequencing they know the
uk variant has 17
key mutations these variants that we're
seeing these changes
give a small advantage in terms of the
ability of the virus to replicate or
transmit
this has a lot to do with the spike
protein which is critical to how the
virus spreads
a portion of the spike binds to a
receptor on human cells
like a key fitting into a lock this
enables it to enter
and infect scientists found that the uk
variant spike proteins have eight amino
acid changes
previous research appears to show that
some of these changes
may be increasing the protein's ability
to cling onto
and enter human cells this could be
making it more transmissible which means
a higher vaccination rate may be needed
to reach herd immunity
another big question is the virulence or
how harmful
these new versions of the virus could be
scientists say
that most likely the new variants don't
cause a more severe form of covit19
another question is whether the new
versions will show up on tests
early data appears to show that most
covet and antibody testing
will continue to work we should still be
able to tell if you have covid
what's less clear is that we can tell if
you have a specific variant or not
the most pressing issue is whether
vaccines will still be effective
for the uk variant it appears that they
will however
for the variant originating in south
africa preliminary data is worrying some
scientists
researchers say that any of the more
transmissible variants
could eventually become dominant we've
seen variants take over
in terms of the d614g mutation
and it wouldn't surprise me if the south
african or the uk variant do
a similar thing where it becomes the
dominant variant around the world just
because of a small fitness advantage
or small changes that make the virus
more fit
to try to stem the spread certain
countries like the uk
have already imposed strict lockdown
measures
the number of patients in hospitals in
england is now 40
higher than the first peak in april it
is
inescapable that the facts are changing
and we must change
our response and so we have no choice
but to return to a national lockdown
while the new variants are concerning
experts say that current prevention
measures
should continue to work this isn't
something that's completely overcoming
masks or
distancing and so if these measures are
put in place
in more strict or more effective ways
it'll be just as effective if not more
effective and the outcome may be that
you know
being a little bit more serious about
this will get transmission as a whole to
be
reduced and i think that's an ideal
scientists say the coronavirus pandemic
could be on the cusp of a major shift
but more research is needed to know how
severe the impact
of the new variants will be
you